there are few more shameful confessions
to make
than that we are lonely the basic
assumption
is that no respectable person could ever
feel isolated
unless maybe they just moved country or
been widowed
yet in truth a high degree of loneliness
is an inexorable part
of being a sensitive intelligent human
it's a built-in feature
of a complex existence there are several
big reasons for this
[Music]
much of what we need recognized and
confirmed by others
a lot of what it would be extremely
comforting to share
is going to be disturbing to society at
large
many of the ideas in the recesses of our
minds are too
odd contrary subtle or alarming to be
safely revealed to anyone else
we face a choice between honesty and
acceptability
and understandably mostly choose the
latter
it takes a lot of energy to listen to
another person
and enter sympathetically into their
experiences
we shouldn't blame others for their
failure to focus on who we are
they may want to meet us but we should
accept the energy
with which they will keep the topic of
their own lives
at the center of the conversation we
must all die
alone which really means that our pain
is for us alone to endure others can
throw us words of encouragement but in
every life
we are out on the ocean drowning in the
swell
and others even the nice ones are
standing on the shore
waving cheerily
it's deeply unlikely that we will ever
find someone on exactly the same page of
the soul
as us we will long for utter congruity
but there will be constant dissonance
because we appeared on the earth at
different times
are the product of different families
and experiences
and are just not made of quite the same
fabric
so they won't be thinking just the same
as us on coming out of the cinema
and looking out at the night sky just
when we want them to say something
high flown and beautiful they will
perhaps be remembering a painfully banal
and
untimely detail from an area of domestic
life
or vice versa it is almost
comic we will almost certainly never
meet the people
best qualified to understand us but they
do exist
probably they once walked past us in the
street though neither of us had the
slightest idea
of the potential for connection or maybe
they died in sydney two weeks ago
or won't be born until the 22nd century
it isn't a conspiracy
we would just have needed a lot more
luck
the problem is sure to get worse the
more thoughtful
and perceptive we are there will simply
be less people like us around
it isn't a romantic myth loneliness
truly is
a kind of tax we have to pay to atone
for a certain complexity of mind
the desire to undress someone is for a
long time
far more urgent than the desire for good
conversation
and so we end up locked in relationships
with certain people
we don't have much to say to because we
were once
faithfully interested in the shape of
their nose or the color of their
remarkable
eyes and yet despite all this
we shouldn't be frightened or
discomforted by our pervasive loneliness
at an exasperated moment near the end of
his life the german writer goethe
who appeared to have had a lot of
friends exploded bitterly
no one has ever properly understood me i
have never fully understood anyone no
one
understands anyone else it was a helpful
outburst from such a great man it isn't
our fault
a degree of distance and mutual
incomprehension isn't a sign that life
has gone wrong
it's what we should expect from the very
start and when we do
benefits can follow once we accept
loneliness
we can get creative we can start to send
out messages in a bottle
we can sing write poetry produce books
and blogs
activities stemming from the realization
that people around us
won't ever fully get us but that others
separated across time and space
might just the history of art is the
record of people
who couldn't find anyone in the vicinity
to talk to
and we can take up the coded offer of
intimacy
in say the words of a roman poet who
died in 10 bc
or the lyrics of a singer who described
just our blues
in a recording from nashville in 1963
loneliness makes us more capable of true
intimacy
if ever better opportunities do come
along it heightens the conversations we
have with ourselves
it gives us a character we don't repeat
what everyone else thinks
we develop a point of view we might be
isolated for now
but we'll be capable of far closer more
interesting bonds
with anyone we do eventually locate
loneliness renders us elegant and
strangely alluring
it suggests there's more about us to
understand than the normal patterns of
social intercourse can accommodate
which is something we can take pride in
a sense of isolation truly is
as we suspect but usually prevent
ourselves from feeling from
fear of arrogance a sign of depth
when we admit our loneliness we are
signing up to a club that includes the
people we know
from the paintings of edward hopper the
poems of baudelaire and the songs of
leonard cohen
lonely we enter a long and grand
tradition
we find ourselves surprisingly in great
company
enduring loneliness is almost invariably
better
than suffering the compromises of false
community
loneliness is simply a price we may have
to pay
for holding on to a sincere ambitious
view
of what companionship must and could be
you